Russia's space agency says it will
launch an urgent Mission next month to
replace a damaged Soleus spacecraft
docked at the International Space
Station video shows the capsule is
leaking so officials say three crew
members including an American astronaut
need to need a ride back to Earth Mark
Strassman reports on the plan to bring
them home
and liftoff when the Russian soyuz
launched last September it ferried a
three-man crew to the International
Space Station for a six-month stay but
in December while duck to the station
their ride home suddenly sprung a leak
Russian flight controllers and the
flight controllers here at Mission
Control in Houston have been noticing a
stream of particles coming out of the
soyuz ms-22 vehicle investigators
believe a micro meteoroid a tiny Space
Rock just one millimeter across but
flying 15 000 miles per hour struck a
coolant line that feeds the spacecraft's
radiator and without that coolant
temperatures inside the cabin could
climb above 100 degrees during a return
flight potentially overheating flight
computers
Russian space officials determined the
damage craft is unsafe to fly
essentially stranding its crew Cosmonaut
sergeyev and Dimitri pedalin and NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio to bring the crew
home Russia is fast tracking a
replacement ship to launch in February
this has certainly never happened before
in the history of the space station CBS
News space analyst Bill Harwood they
don't have spare soyuz it's just sitting
in a hangar ready to go on a moment's
notice so they're taking the one for the
next crew they're going to launch the
new soyuz with no one on board and then
the crew that's currently on board the
station they're now going to have to
stay up as if they were another new crew
staying up for six months which is going
to push their flight out to nearly
nearly a year or longer a reminder that
in space even the smallest of threats
carry big risks for CBS mornings I'm
Mark Strassman